[Musique]
oh
j'ai été jugé inapte pour raisons
médicales pendant 11 années consécutives
il était exclu à la sélection médicale
en 1994 la commission médicale m'a
rejeté une fois pour toutes
mais je n'ai pas craqué je n'ai pas
abandonné j'ai réussi à les convaincre
que j'étais prêt et tu retombes
cependant j'avais déjà 38 ans les
consulter la seule question que je
craignais d'entendre de la commission
s'était n'est-il pas trop tard pour vous
de commencer cette question n'a jamais
été posée je me sentais comme un peu
comme à la ligne d'arrivée mais comme si
je m'approchais de la ligne de départ
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
traces bienvenue à bord station spatiale
internationale c'est le secteur russe
fiodor iourtchikhine a effectué son
premier vol dans l'espace à 43 en onze
jours dans la station spatiale requiert
quatre années de préparation
il n'avait même pas sa propre cabine et
devait dormir dans un sac de couchage un
mouvement après son deuxième vol était
beaucoup plus long
le voilà avec charles simonyi touriste
spatial en réalité ce n'était pas si
facile à l'époque les cosmonautes ont
failli être évacué sur la terre les
ordinateurs du secteur russes sont
souvent tombés en panne après son retour
sur terre fiodor iourtchikhine était sûr
que c'était son dernier vol d'abord à
cause de l'âge et puis parce que ma
famille a commencé à s'opposer avec
véhémence à la poursuite de ma carrière
que j'ai même eu l'idée qu'il fallait
que je me trouve un boulot sur terre
pourtant il ne faut jamais dire jamais
le voilà de nouveau dans la station il
se prépare à effectuer une sortie dans
l'espace les jo les garçons sont prêts à
agir prête à courir les jupons les dames
n'ayez pas peur
nos chances sont bien plus mince
maintenant
il a tenu la torche olympique dans
l'espace et a fait un concert en
apesanteur
maintenant je dors iourtchikhine à 57
ans il se prépare pour son cinquième vol
ce n'est pas pour rien qu'il a passé
onze ans de sa vie à essayer de
rejoindre l'équipe des cosmonautes
depuis son enfance il savait que c'était
sa vocation fermer la cabine
yobo good j'avais deux ans et demi quand
j'ai tendu la main vers une grappe de
raisin que je suis tombé par la fenêtre
nous habitions au premier étage mes
parents m'ont emmené à l'hôpital et tout
le monde pensait que j'avais perdu
l'esprit parce que je disais aux
médecins que j'étais comme youri
gagarine
vingt ans ont passé depuis que j'ai été
admis dans les rangs des cosmonautes
doivent cependant tout ce temps ma
famille était dans un état de tension
constante houston
quand j'ai décidé de voler et que j'ai
été approuvé pour cet été un petit choc
dont je rejoins grand peut-être une
personne ne s'y attendait à vrai dire je
ne m'y attendais pas non plus motivés
venir je bourre
sand copeaux mineurs c'est un rêve mais
où tu vas j'ai toujours voulu voir ça
[Musique]
combat j'inspire l'air à pleins poumons
je repousse la terre et je commence à
monter au dessus de l'atmosphère et je
vois la terre dans dix ans nous je
flotte
je flotte donc et puis je me rends
compte que je manque d'air et que je
dois retourner sur terre
c'est un beau rêve je les ai vus à
plusieurs reprises
j'aimerais pouvoir prendre ma
respiration pour repousser et voler à
nouveau
[Musique]
bien vient vers moi je ne pouvais pas
comprendre pourquoi prendre de tels
risques
pourquoi se séparer pour si longtemps de
plus elle était totalement contre
j'étais tout à fait contre oui tout à
fait un soir je lisais un journal je
suis tombé sur un article utiliser
l'équipage de la 52e expédition a été
sélectionné ses membres sont et j'ai vu
un nom de famille qui m'étaient
familiers
j'ai pris une photo je n'ai envoyé à mon
mari aucune réponse
il semblait qu'il avait peur de ma
réaction pourquoi tu ne m'as pas répondu
alors
tant que nous pousse à elle ne m'a pas
vraiment donné la permission de partir
nous avons en quelque sorte et éviter la
question
bien que j'espère toujours qu'ils
viendront assister au lancement
[Applaudissements]
ok
pour tous ceux qui peuvent l'entendre
l'équipage du vaisseau spatial soyouz mc
05 indicatif d'appel 1px a atterri
descendants l'altitude 200 m faites vous
connaître d'une certaine façon
atterrissage forcé les cosmonautes était
censé atterrir dans la steppe
mais au lieu de ça ils ont atterri dans
une forêt isolée moments de tension mais
on voit des gens qui se promènent autour
du vaisseau spatial de toute évidence ce
n'était qu'un exercice
ce sont ce qu'on appelle des exercices
de survie au cas où on interdirait dans
un endroit où il n'y a personne et où il
faudra survivre
bonjour il se pose où nous pouvons
utiliser l'équipement qui atterrira avec
nous cela inclut un parachute dont on
peut faire une sorte de tipis un énorme
avis g
après des exercices conjoints avec les
américains nous avons appris à
construire des villes femme qui
permettent de se réchauffer bien mieux
que dans une hutte de branchages sauce
[Rires]
quand nous avons été sélectionnés dans
le même équipage j'étais très content
paolo nespoli
c'est son troisième vol jacques fischer
avec les yeux qui brillent
juste à côté de nous c'était nouveau il
s'attendait à ce que je lui mâche le
travail et que je lui sers tout sur un
plateau
ma vie
en a eu besoin de quelques mises au
point et du temps pour s'habituer les
uns aux autres comment ça va jazzer
guèye
comment vas-tu mon patron
ça y est l'entraînement est terminée
allons-y n'abandonner quand même pas le
commandant qu'est ce qu'il y a vous
pourriez au moins de délier au départ
c'était déjà une bonne équipe et il a
été décidé de la démanteler le programme
spatial a été modifié il y aura un
équipage de deux personnes au lieu de
trois
fiodor dira seulement avec jacques
richer ont plus le lancement a été
reporté de plusieurs mois
les préparatifs devait être accéléré
toutes ces difficultés nous ont vraiment
rapproché lui chaut nous étions une
équipe assez uni depuis le début mai
deux entre nous et en reste et nous
avons fait un boulot colossal
vous pouvez pas imaginer le travail
qu'on a dû fournir en si peu de temps
fiodor nicolaïte c'est une personne
géniale
si l'apparence d'un russe vraiment dur
mais il est tout doux à l'intérieur
c'est quelqu'un qu'il y a toujours des
conseils sont donc vraiment à ce que
lorsque nous irons sur la station
spatiale
j'aurai d'autres conseils sur comment
faire doucement
teddy kronish co
je m'entraîne avec lui depuis si
longtemps que d'après ce qu'il dit ou
l'expression de son visage ou d'après
seulement son langage corporel
je sais ce qu'il pense nous sommes comme
un vieux couple marié et quand je ne
comprends pas yanni pognon il utilisera
ses 20 ans d'expérience et l'exprimera
en anglais et ensuite nous pourrons
continuer toi c'est la course
tu opèrent selon la procédure courte -
selon la longue et cela va travailler
avec la courte et puis je vérifie tous
les points pour voir comment ça marche
fiodor nikolaïevitch parle anglais et
j'essaie de le dire en russe
rousski haziq rosli che comment dire en
anglais
refermez le saas dans notre équipage
s'est refermée de achiou
ne pas fermer tout à fait pas tout à
fait pas complètement ça tout à fait
voilà intelligent là
[Musique]
avant chaque vol fiodor iourtchikhine
passe quelques mois à houston pour
apprendre à travailler dans la section
américaine de la station
il vit toujours au même endroit
normalement accompagné de sa famille
c'est notre maison j'espère au moins que
ma femme viendrait avec moi cette voie
mais maintenant nous avons un petit fils
larissa s'est entièrement consacré à lui
elle va le voir chaque semaine un petit
10 morts est-ce que tu regarde mon petit
il s'intéresse à autre chose
quel potelets montpetit di mare chicose
recueil non je n'ai pas eu la
possibilité d'acheter des couches avec
des inserts mais je continuerai à
chercher maintenant tout le monde va
l'entendre
c'est notre endroit préféré
nous avons filmé une de nos vidéos de
famille ici
[Musique]
ils sont venus comme un famille cadette
avait seulement un an elle a prôné à
flotter et l'achat la plus âgée ne
faisait que plonger
cela me vient à l'esprit chaque fois que
je viens ici
je ne sais pas pourquoi peut-être parce
que je vieillis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non il soit attendre on passe pas à cet
ensemble et ça me manque terriblement
nous nous rattrapons le soir comment
c'est possible
et encore seulement s'ils ne travaillent
pas la mise à l'abri dans une vaste île
et fournira son téléphone doit être
étendue complète c'est des fois j'ai
pris l'habitude vais tendre leçons de
son téléphone discrètement je me fais
grande et après bien sûr quel prix pomme
omnium je me souviens quand il y avait
son exposition au musée j'ai emmené ma
classe quoi ils lui ont posé toutes
sortes de questions c'était très
intéressant quand on est rentré à la
maison je lui demandé papa pourquoi tu
m'as jamais raconter tout ça moi aussi
je suis allée avec ma classe voir
l'exposition de papa pour l'écouter
il faut mettre votre biais en dessous
houston qui adore s'entraîne sur des
simulateurs américain mais il a volé
dans deux fois et s'y connaît si bien
qu'il est parfois difficile de dire qui
enseigne à qui ça c'est la position
correcte ça c'est pas bon ça ce n'est
pas la bonne hélas cette ampoule en
dessous c'est pas correct
[Musique]
ce n'est pas une erreur parce que c'est
comme ça et que c'est écrit ici riga
mais je mets ici un pont pour me le
rappeler
ok mais tu es une étoile ok on a une
étoile ou un autre je vais montrer aux
gars la corse père c'est exactement ce
qu'il ne faut la majorité de nos
entraînements sont consacrés à chercher
des possibles situations d'urgence dans
le segment américain aujourd'hui ils
nous ont observés de près pour s'assurer
que nous étions côte à côte nous devons
nous contrôler l'un l'autre tout le
temps et nous voir imaginez s'il ya un
court-circuit s'il ya un incendie
du coup si vous avez été électrocuté et
vous avez perdu connaissance que faut-il
faire ensuite
c'est comme ça que d'anciens cosmonautes
quand les formateurs sont tellement
contents de l'entraînement qu'il le
laisse partir deux heures plus tôt et
qu'il peut déjeuner à son endroit
préféré
ce n'est pas de la restauration rapide
c'est un vrai hamburger avec une vraie
côtelettes
ici on vous demande même comment voulez
vous qu'on vous le fasse bien cuit à
point saignante les petits pains son
frère ils les font cuire sur place tout
est naturel
donc votre médecin approuve-t-il
l'alimentation saine c'est quoi c'est la
nourriture qu'on a envie de manger
[Musique]
non
tête pour lucho c'était je me suis un
peu laissé aller ces six derniers mois
nous pousse pas du point de vue de la
forme physique mais plutôt du poids les
médecins m'ont menacé du doigt
strogonoff trop
certains sont même frappé du poing sur
la table juste le postaux ma femme s'en
prend à moi chaque fois que nous allons
en vacances
je lui ai promis d'avoir une tablette de
chocolat et elle n'est pas là et je
l'aurais apparemment jamais tout a
disparu pour de bon c'est dommage
c'est réconcilier avec sa femme à femme
mais moi
exit boulou j'aimerais pouvoir fermer le
sas laisser tout le monde derrière moi
et m'occuper de mes affaires
tous les moteurs à la vitesse de vol et
des collages le 65e vaisseau
d'approvisionnement progresse à décoller
et a commencé son voyage de deux jours à
la station spatiale internationale
ce vaisseau d'approvisionnement devaient
amener du matériel scientifique des
bagages de la nourriture et de l'oxygène
pour les cosmonautes de liesse mais il
n'a pas réussi à atteindre l'altitude
requise et n'est jamais parvenu à la
station certains de ces débris ont brûlé
dans l'atmosphère dense d'autres sont
tombés sur la terre c'est ce que nous
avons vu il ya trente minutes
de toute évidence le vaisseau
d'approvisionnement progresse 59 a
commencé à tourner sur lui-même
les défaillances ont été détectés dans
le système automatique d'arrimage
boston quand es-tu vous stressez lorsque
la navette s'était écrasé d'autres
questions s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
la ventilation est bonne et la pression
entraînement finaux à la cité des
étoiles
fiodor iourtchikhine et sergueï
riazanski apprête à lancer des
satellites
il n'y arrive pas trop pour le moment
est ce que vous voulez que je vous
rapproche un petit peu la barre pour que
vous vous soulevez ce serait plus
confortable
ces regards il va bientôt rejoindre
l'équipe de la station
ensemble les astronautes était censé
sortir dans l'espace dans de nouveau
scaphandre dont un était dans le
vaisseau qui vient de s'écraser
maintenant fiodor devra ajuster le vieux
scaph l'andra les ss un désastre au nom
que portera lors de leur sortie dans
l'espace
avant le lancement l'équipe visite
traditionnellement la place rouge pour
honorer la mémoire du premier cosmonaute
même la pluie ne pouvait pas les
empêcher d'observer la tradition même
s'il savait très bien qu'au cas où l'un
d'entre eux tomberait malade le
lancement serait reporté
c'est la première fois que ma femme
après la décision de visiter la place
rouge sosno mais c'était sa propre
décision me suis dit que j'étais surpris
parce que nous ne sommes jamais venu ici
ensemble soufflé cette fois ma fille et
elle voulait poser des fleurs ensemble
avec moi ils sont moins bons joueurs ils
se trouvent
j'ai participé à cette cérémonie
plusieurs fois mais je n'ai jamais vu
une pluie pareil et il est docteur le
docteur il est avec nous une mesure
préventive
j'adore c'est un médicament docteur de
vrais gens prendre aussi bien sûr merci
à ta santé jack à ta santé
[Musique]
[Rires]
dans la feuille d'avis
comment allez vous pour être honnête pas
bien du tout je vais mal la pression
monte
tu te sens pas bien c'est ça mais ça va
passer
nous tenons bon
ma grande muraille en miniature
ma famille c'est ma propre grande
muraille de chine
jack c'est notre hôtel regarde nous
sommes au cinquième étage
jacques loge à l'hôtel juste en face de
la place rouge jacques loue une chambre
d'hôtel 20000 dollars la minute rend
juste pour une nuit
en fait jacques est incroyable un
romantique comme moi vous le sentez way
nous sommes tout simplement amoureux
comme des fous parce que nous ne prenons
pas notre relation pour acquise grâce au
fait qu'elle soit une personne forte
compétente est incroyable je peux
vraiment déplacé des montagnes
je l'appelle jamais elisabeth c'est trop
long j'appelle toujours ma biche mon
lapin ou autre chose du genre un peu
sexy c'est tellement sexy
la soeur aînée de larissa irina et moi
nous avons travaillé côte à côte pendant
des années et quand j'ai vu larissa pour
la première fois j'ai commencé à venir
dans le bureau et je vais demander y a
pas un fax pour moi j'irais pas un fax
moment quelles facs mais oui quelles
facs quand je les ai rencontrés pour la
première fois je les trouvais très
ennuyeux mais vous savez parfois ça peut
servir
je me sentais toujours blessé qu'un feu
de relisez le travail vient toujours en
premier je savais je pouvais ressentir à
quel point elle nous aimer mais il
continue à dire que le travail était sa
priorité et ça me faisait mal
je suppose que c'est la femme en moi qui
trouvais ça blessant je me souviens pas
quand exactement ça a changé mais après
l'un des vols
il a dit vous êtes la chose la plus
précieuse de ma vie tu vois qu'elle
baignait au fromage si les trouves
comment très bon elle se moque de moi
se plaisant au sommet si vous dites ça
je fais des analyses plus tard
aujourd'hui mais je peux boire de l'eau
elle et boit de l'eau demain ce sera une
journée agitée
il va falloir se lever est il faut lever
tôt et à 19h45
vous savez lorsque l'équipe est là les
femmes sont ici mais à distance
mais au moment du départ je marche main
dans la main n'est ce pas je sais pas
quand tu veux faire cette fois c'est
comme ça que l'anxiété se manifestent
malheureusement
tout va bien se passer tout va bien se
passer
je reviendrai je reviendrai tu m'entends
j'ai pensé que ça allait être triste
c'était une fête tous les amis sont
venus au moins bien il y avait de la
tristesse aussi mais faudra n'aime pas
ça peut-être qu'au fond cela lui ferait
plaisir mais il ne serait pas content je
pense qu'en tant de quoi de me voir
pleurer
il est très romantique s'ils achètent
des roses il prend un énorme bouquet
nous n'avons pas toujours eu deux gros
bouquets nous avons eu des moments
difficiles
à l'époque nous n'avions pas de voitures
nous avions l'habitude de nous promener
jusqu'à la gare et c'était assez loin
quarante minutes environ et nous nous
promenions j'avais l'habitude de le
prendre par la main il prenait la mienne
ils la mettaient dans sa poche j'aimais
beaucoup me promener comme ça et puis
quand nous avons acheté une voiture
j'étais un peu triste ne plus ressentir
cette chaleur de sa main je me sentais
si bien insécurité
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
jack
regardez nous s'il vous plaît le dehors
nicolas liebich allez vous utiliser des
engrais les plus tard après le départ de
la presse sans accent c'est le soleil
s'est caché tout le geste que vous
faites toujours qu'est ce qu'on attend
le plus le lancement ou la visite de nos
femmes nous ne sommes pas encore prêts
les femmes sont la priorité
ce petit groupe habillée d'une marinière
vraiment très sympa alors dites nous
comment ma dessus tête de bonne humeur
c'est génial que vous soyez venu je suis
très content c'est ce que nous voulons
entendre
je suis très heureux notamment important
koulitch et des autres acolytes liocha
bien ici il ya même une bougie j'ai tout
à porter pour super la ramaz chéri passe
le docteur il va vérifier mais vérifier
quoi
cissé orthodoxe voix s'il y en a pas
d'accord ça va aller plus loin quand ils
viennent de moscou qui nous ne parlons
qu'à travers la vitre on ne sait jamais
si la personne à des virus ou pas le
progrès spatial est un projet compliqué
les enjeux sont très élevés au football
et que faire si quelqu'un tombe malade
c'était dur la toute première fois mais
nous sommes des adultes le même prénom
même si on se sent un peu triste à
l'intérieur ma femme me dit comment puis
je ne peuvent-ils pas comprendre
on a tellement vie est foutue mais elle
est mon petit soldat de plomb
inébranlable ils essaient de matin drire
[Musique]
il a un vrai caractère d'homme chaque
fois qu'il a un problème je le découvre
plus tard je vois bien que quelque chose
le prend il est nerveux
nous sommes très proches je peux sentir
son état mental même s'il ne dit rien
mais ça sert à rien de lui poser des
questions
il ne me répondra par titre mais quand
il est soulagé quand il a résolu ce
problème il peut venir me dire lara j'ai
eu un souci mais pourquoi tu fais ça tu
te sentirais si bien si tu m'en avait
parlé
non je suis un homme j'allais le réseau
de moi même
les rouges qu'il ya le chou il ya
beaucoup de choses que je ne sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quant à la peur
je dis toujours que seul un imbécile ne
connaît pas la peur une personne normale
a toujours peur l'important est de
contrôler ses peurs
[Musique]
pourtant c'est dur de se dire au revoir
on ne s'y habitue pas le même si ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'on ne peut
pas ses habitués on se dit chaque fois
qui donnez moi la force de traverser
cette épreuve
[Musique]
moins de cinq minutes avant le décollage
décollage
[Musique]
c'est n'importe quoi de dire que le
lanceur est en fait il est vivant au
delà sa propre vie qu il a des organes
du sang qui le nourriture dans notre sa
vie n'est pas longue
mais son travail est tout simplement
génial
c'est au seuil ou ms 0,4 à temps leur
bip circulent terrestre
[Musique]
alors j'ai les filles tu as besoin d
aide
tu veux je te porte les fleurs non sauf
celle de mon mari il nous a offert alors
je les garde
il nous a félicités a transmis des
lettres pour moi et les filles me les
lieront plus tard il y aura beaucoup de
larmes
[Musique]
on
oh
elle a le seuil des franchises phares
fiodor iourtchikhine ci effectue son
cinquième vol dans l'espace
il est à bord de la station spatiale
internationale le contrôle de mission de
l'igas a sa mosquée et sur la chaîne sg
anc
les gars on vous voit vous avez l'air
bien vous nous recevez bien la ramaz
chéri dumas souvent demandé pourquoi tu
veux faire tout ça encore une fois pour
pouvoir dire de cette attitude à quel
point je t'aime tu es la seule et unique
personne pour moi dans ce monde là rares
ma chérie je t'aime et méfie aussi bien
sûr
[Applaudissements]
ici rien n'est comme sur terre ils
doivent flotter plutôt que marcher ce
n'est pas si facile de s'y habituer
ils dorment debout entre dans leur sac
de couchage et leur ferme
obligatoirement donc les bras ne flotte
pas en apesanteur
il faut savoir s'entendre la station il
y a trop de risque ici pour perdre du
temps dans des conflits violents la vue
depuis la fenêtre du vaisseau spatial
blatter vous voyez ces tâches sur les
hublots bolchoï chess la plupart d'entre
elles sont des marques fait par des
micrométéorites comme fluide et et le
danger est donc réel
vous pouvez le voir j'aime bien l'idée
que nous soyons une équipe unie dans la
station spatiale internationale
nous comprenons que nous sommes
dépendants les uns des autres notre
survie dépend de notre coopération
c'est un exemple parfait pour les hommes
politiques qui pour le monde entier
d'ailleurs sur le comment il faut
travailler ensemble pour faire de
grandes choses
ce qui importe le plus ce sont plus ou
moins les mêmes choses vous savez si je
commence à dire quelque chose et que
fiodor n'est pas d'accord ou bien s'il
dit quelque chose et que je ne partage
pas l'idée encore sans rigoler en dix
ans le voilà l'ours russe fort tu fais
quoi à jack on peut faire des blagues là
dessus on comprend que le sujet dont
nous parlons n'est pas aussi important
que notre amitié ou les valeurs que nous
partageons ça ne vaudrait pas la peine
de se bagarrer
la chose la plus magnifique dans le
segment russe ce sont les cosmonautes
russes comme j'adore notre commande les
hublots ici ils sont très bien super
qualité on peut donc faire des photos
nous avons aussi des systèmes qui
permettent à la station de fonctionner
au quart de gramme est la dernière chose
que je voulais montrer c'est ma photo
préférée parce qu'elle représente une
chose importante c'est youri gagarine
avec une colons parce qu'on étudie
l'espace tous ensemble si vous avez
remarqué j'ai un t-shirt russes et les
chaussettes et américaines c'est un
projet international qui travaillons
ensemble
c'était mon blog de la semaine roux
belle journée
vous savez mon rêve est de rassembler
tous les hommes politiques les envoyer à
la station spatiale n'est pas la nôtre
je vois où il habite c'est la planète
terre qu'ils voient elle n'a pas de
frontières qu'il voit à quel point les
petites fragile protège on l'a dit et
tous ces politiciens ne laisserions pas
repartir avant qu'il n'arrive à trouver
un accord mon ami astronautes américains
dit ce serait bien de ne jamais les
faire redescendre direction action nous
soussignés avons fait cette déclaration
qui stipule que la responsabilité du
segment russe 16 50 51 a été transféré
de oleg nowitzki fiodor iourtchikhine
responsable du segment russe de l'iss s
51 52 segment russe de l'iss s 51 52 on
met le tampon du segment russe par
données reçues
grignard l'équipe changes
oleg nowitzki est thomas pesquet
reviennent sur terre fiodor
iourtchikhine et maintenant commandant
de la station
il restera seul dans le segment russe
il sera responsable des dizaines
d'expérience et du maintien de la
station
il a tellement de choses à faire qu'il
n'a même pas le temps de préparer le
dîner ses collègues américains viennent
à l'aide
l'astronaute peggy whitson reste à la
station et travaillera avec jack
[Musique]
tous les soirs quand il préparait le
dîner il faisait aussi un repas pour moi
ministre belge arrive pas
[Musique]
si tu arrives pas
cette expérience est la plus délicieuse
on a cultivé la salade en apesanteur
on la mange et après bien sûr on fait
également des expériences biologiques et
physiques
on étudie le fonctionnement des cellules
souches et développe des médicaments
pour soigner le cancer
cette expérience est la plus importante
pour jack fischer sa fille avait un
cancer
les astronautes sont aussi des cobayes
en quelque sorte le contrôle de mission
surveille constamment leur santé éveil
surtout à ce qu'il fasse suffisamment de
sport nous avons un appareil spécial
trop d'abord le trouver et c'est dans le
mur
génial nous devons nous entraîner 2h à
2h30 par jour un peu près parce que si
on ne fait pas bien les exercices les
muscles les os disparaîtront et on se
transformera en vieillard de 92 ans les
pluies la femme sexy ne tu aimeras plus
[Musique]
vous passez le bonjour je vous appelle
directement depuis leur
ah ouais c'est bien ah oui
on est dans sa cabine et moscou est à
côté au nord on regarde sa montre et on
sait que c'est l'heure du thé dans la
famille et on n'est pas avec ses avocats
toni parfois on se parle et on comprend
qu'une personne ne peut pas toujours
avoir la même humeur et on comprend que
quelque chose est arrivé à la maison et
on ne peut rien faire un tel poids
mouche mouche
tu ne comprends très bien
et ce jour là
il s'est passé quelque chose
que je ne voulais pas lui dire mais moi
même j'étais très triste je ne me
permettait pas de montrer trop
d'émotions de dire à quel point je me
sentais mal à quel point il me manquait
et comment je voulais qu'il soit près de
moi je pense que c'est parce qu'il
fallait faire je faisais semblant
d'aller bien il a appelé je me suis
ressaisi je lui parlais et puis il a dit
tout d'un coup lara qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et je réponds à tout va bien rien
c'est passé si la rai s'est passé
quelque chose l'an tout va bien je lui
dis tout le monde va bien falloir te
vient cette optique haute et ils
continuent non tu me le dis au jeu
décent tout de suite il a dit ça s'est
sévèrement
je vais descendre tout de suite et j'ai
répondu ça suffit d'abord tu as
complétons programme et puis tu rentres
deux dames la grève
regardes tu ne seras pas capable de
tenir sur tes pieds il faudra tenir par
la main
j'ai ajusté le scaphandre que sergueï
riazanski devait porter lors de la
sortie dans l'espace et j'étais assez
nerveux vous pour ce n'est qu'après la
sortie dans l'espace que j'ai été
soulagé le travail a réussi tout est bon
ici puis avait des doutes aussi propre
de l'autre côté tu y vas tuera peut-être
le nom de la grue et moi sur l'anneau et
nous nous retrouvons là sérieux il
recommande de prendre le petit diamètre
de l'anneau pour ne pas trop s'éloigner
les uns des autres nous ne nous perdrons
pas ici
[Musique]
la sphère s'approche toutes ses couleurs
flamboyantes
le soleil se lève tout doute au nitinol
ce sujet on commence à sentir la chaleur
du soleil à travers le scaphandre car il
devient une seconde peau
[Musique]
lorsqu'on se déplace de l'ombre et quand
se trouve au soleil grosso modo il fait
plus ou moins 150 degrés 150 degrés sur
la surface sous les rayons directs du
soleil et -150 quand on est à l'ombre
jetée une ruse
[Musique]
ma
la barre de la main gauche et tu lancera
de la main droite
oui je ne sais pas où mettre les pieds
il ya une ancre la sarriette tu peux
mettre le pied gauche dans l'antre si tu
y parviens auquel j'adore préparons-nous
pour le lancement
sergei qui est prêt je vais essayer de
trouver un moyen de le lancer doucement
au kef et le doucement donc ça ne tourne
pas dans ces prêts lancement reçues
allez on passe au suivant je vais
maintenant un petit éléphant ben ouais
[Musique]
tu m'as temps chaque fois que furent
d'un revient il sent et j'aime pas cette
odeur elle nous sépare
c'est quoi cette odeur celle du met à
lubrifier non ouais sa propre odeur non
c'est pas la sienne l'odeur de la
station oui ses cheveux sa peau sont
imprégnés de cette odeur est ce qui est
étrange ce que je lui lève les cheveux
le jour de son retour
mais le d'heure ne disparaît pas je ne
sais pas pourquoi il en est tellement
imprégné soir j'ai vécu tous ses vols
long et plus je grandis
juste ça fait peur quand je pense que
c'est parce qu'on se rend plus compte de
ce que c'est cette fois je m'inquiète
beaucoup je sais que si quelque chose
arrive les gens ne pourront rien faire
cette incapacité d'agir ça fait peur
c'est sur l'inconnu
non confirmant la séparation nous voyons
le message ssvp le système d'arrimage et
transferts internes ont été séparés la
première manoeuvre sera effectuée d'un
deux minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque voyage devrait se terminer à la
maison sans quelqu'un devrait vous
attendre où que l'on soit parti comme ce
n'est pourtant vous tous j'aimerais si
loin pour ma famille pour leur prouver à
ma femme par exemple que je suis un
homme un vrai et un colis mais aussi par
mézague nous c'est que je suis prêt
encore à faire des choses insensées et
le
laissez passer ne me laissez pas tomber
les gars non non il va me reposer pas
trop vite les gars sur lever les pieds
plus bas de poussière je ferai semblant
de rouler ou même de courir d'être tous
contents
quelle réaction je pourrais avoir
bien sûr je peux devenir très ému
c'est quelqu'un qui aimait très proche
qui m'est cher comment ne pas
m'inquiéter
quand je le vois après un long moment et
qu'il n'est plus dans la même forme
physique qu'au moment de partir eh bien
ça me donne de l'amertume
[Musique]
oh
mon
[Musique]
consonances chaque fois de retour après
le vol je me surprends à penser si
seulement je pouvais y passer une
semaine de plus certaines choses n'ont
pas été achevés je n'ai toujours pas
pris la photo de la grande muraille de
chine zhu avec le taj mahal ça ne marche
pas non plus c'est toujours brumeux là
bas quand je suis dans l'espace à la
maison me manque
et quand je suis chez moi je veux aller
dans l'espace
et s'il m'appelait il me disait tu sais
il y a une mission pour toi et tu prêt
ou pas quant au fond ligne
[Musique]
ma famille pense que c'est mon dernier
vol dans l'espace
je suis quelqu'un qui peut faire ne
jamais dire jamais
[Musique]
bondissait j'ai demandé à dieu ne m'a
pas encore répondu millette mémoire au
tennis
[Musique]